Jalen Walker was 25 years old when
police in Akron Ohio tried to pull him
over for a broken tail light last June
Ohio's attorney general says Walker
fired a gun at police from his car then
took off on foot police chased him then
shot him 46 times how does a traffic
stop end like this
I can tell you the answer
it's because Jalen was black
Jalen was stopped because he was black
he was murdered because he was black
and there is no indictment today because
he is black Monday's announcement that
the eight police officers involved will
not face criminal charges has been met
with anger from Walker supporters there
would be no peace
of Ohio there would be no peace in
America until black men are able to walk
down the street without being gunned
down until black men are able to walk
wake up and walk outside without the
fear of being murdered by Saint
sanctioned violence we will not rest
Akron has been on edge since some
protests over Walker's death turned
destructive last summer now the city has
boarded up several government buildings
in anticipation of more anger on the
streets I would ask that during these
times of tension and Trauma that you
turn towards one another and not on each
other I firmly believe that no Akron
Police Officer in the course of their
duties wants to discharge their firearm
at another human being and resulting in
the loss of life
any time that happens it's a tragic day
for our community and the Akron Police
Department
the police chief says the officers who
shot Walker will remain on
administrative Duty as the department
now launches an internal review
meanwhile akron's congresswoman says
she's asked the U.S Department of
Justice to launch a civil rights
investigation
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
at least three people have died and
several other